voici une compilation de mary but pour
qu'ils restent mitchell en droit social
admirez monde ancien cacique bien sûr au
cati c'était ma petite chérie
tous les deux ont fait des randonnées
des ricochets il faut que je renoue le
lien je sais que tu peut arranger ça bon
c'est notre dernière soirée ensemble
avant que cathy part pour ses études
si on posait nos téléphones etc on se
regardait dans les yeux pendant 10
secondes
on commence pourtant portable maintenant
quel droit de cligner des yeux c'est
juste une connexion visuel pourquoi tu
as besoin de tout ça pour m'emmener à
l'aéroport c'est parce que j'ai annulé
tomber l'avion nous allons te conduira
ton école en famille maman ton père il a
joué un peu solo aaron tu viens aussi ça
peut être cool d'être ensemble en
voiture pendant des heures
un enfant paraît qu'il ya des supers
randonnée dans le coin
donnez vos pré fall va lancer la plus
extraordinaire de ses créations
voici leurs robots assistants le tout
dernier né de la famille la bouteille
nous vous promettons qu'ils ne
deviendront jamais jamais maléfique
merci de rester calme pendant qu'un
nouveau capture
ma moi c'est quoi ça
key
prédation humain quelle est cette
étrange créature enfant j
ap ap la technologie qui se révolte des
robots qui envahissent les rues pas le
temps de te laver les mains moites
inquiète les mitchell ont toujours été
bizarre c'est ce qui fait leur force en
raison de la graine les enfants il se
pourrait même qu'on soit c'est bizarre
pour sauver le monde a ri vauban
ouais mais là non